madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi 1er août
ce sont les chiffres qui inquiètent et
qui s'annonce au coeur de la prochaine
campagne électorale la délinquance a
augmenté de près de 10% au cours du
premier semestre pour l'opposition c'est
le résultat de la politique de lionel
jospin en corse alors que des colis
piégés sont désamorcées aux domiciles de
personnalités nationalistes
le flnc met en garde l'heure est à la
lutte disent les clandestins seule une
amnistie peut régler les problèmes aux
etats-unis conformément aux voeux de
george bush que la chambre des
représentants se prononce contre le
clonage humain y compris à des fins
thérapeutiques
mais à quoi ont pu servir autant de
médicaments dont certains dopants que la
délégation française avait emmené aux
jeux de sydney pas au traitement des
athlètes affirment les médecins
et puis la canicule passages pluvieux et
orageux s'annonce par l'ouest en
attendant c'est toujours la chaleur pour
le plus grand plaisir des habitants et
des vacanciers de normand mais d'abord
cette attaque n'a fourgon blindé à
vénissieux près de lyon un malfaiteur a
été tué un convoyeur de fonds grièvement
blessé
l'attaqué a eu lieu vers 15h50 15h50 de
vente une agence du crédit agricole
vincent fourcade et thierry simonet vers
15h30 un fourgon blindé se garent en
bordure de 7 agences bancaires du centre
ville de vénissieux une banlieue réputés
difficiles à l'est de lyon un convoyeur
descend il s'apprête à recharger le
distributeur automatique quand un homme
armé d'une kalachnikov surgit et ouvre
le feu sans sommation
il a tenté des coups de feu et il y
avait des enfants qui étaient dans le
bassin qu'ils ont vite couru en face
l'espace en duo la chanson de sel rideau
et ont appelé la police et quand ils ont
ouvert le rideau il y avait le convoyeur
qui était par terre qui saigne et
pourtant grièvement blessé le convoyeur
parvient tout de même à riposté avec son
arme de service
le gilet pare-balles que porte le
malfaiteur ne lui est d'aucune utilité
il s'effondre mortellement blessé deux
hommes également masqué tente alors de
le charger à bord de leur véhicule mais
sans succès ils s'enfuiront sur le corps
de leurs complices et sans butin on
avait donc young boys et il y avait deux
individus donc un qui conduisait un
autre m'inquiétait un train de prendre
son collègue en fête et de le remettre
dans la voiture mais en fait c'était pas
moi je pensais que c'était des sacs avec
de l'argent en fin de compte c'était son
collègue qui décidez de rang métreur
d'un véhicule média rêvez pas rapidement
un large dispositif de sécurité a été
déployé autour de l' agence bancaire
tandis que dans tout le département du
rhône
policiers et gendarmes déployés leurs
barrages afin d'appréhender les deux
braqueurs toujours en fuite
et ce braquage intervient alors que sont
publiés les chiffres officiels de la
délinquance pour le premier semestre et
comme on s'y attendait ils ne sont pas
bons + 9,58 % sur la période
un mauvais résultat et qui va encore un
peu plus alimenté la polémique sur la
sécurité patrick fandio et martin rennie
l'intérieur ce jour là la séance était
houleuse pour daniel vaillant harcelés
par les questions de l'opposition sur
l'insécurité il avait fait une promesse
j'ai demandé à monsieur le directeur
général de la police nationale de
publier t juillet les chiffres du
premier semestre 2001 et j'espère ce
sera de nature à vous rassurer sur les
chiffres publiés ce matin ne sont pas
vraiment de nature à rassurer les élus
de l'opposition
les faits de criminalité délinquance
sont en forte hausse +9 perdu 2 58% par
rapport au premier semestre 2010 le bond
est encore plus spectaculaire + 18 %
dans les zones rurales autour des
grandes agglomérations
sous la responsabilité des gendarmes
ce qui fait exploser les chiffres ce
sont surtout les vols vols à l'italienne
vols à la roulotte vols de téléphones
portables ou de cartes bleues des vols
souvent avec violence
opérée par de petits délinquants qui se
déplacent de plus en plus vite de
département en département
autre tendance la baisse des gardes à
vue dans les commissariats un recul de
près de 10% pour certains syndicats
c'est un effet pervers de la loi sur la
présomption d'innocence
un texte qui donne plus de droits aux
suspects vous savez que la même personne
interpellée peu à être dans le même mois
interpellé dix fois et sept personnels
pour la retrouver dans la rue le
lendemain sur l'interpellation
et là aussi ça faut augmenter c'est
c'est 10 % ça ne gêne pas du tout je
vais pas surpris du tout avec l'annnonce
de 3000 policiers supplémentaires en
2002 le gouvernement espère inverser la
tendance
à la veille des élections et du côté de
l'opposition le rpr attribue ce mauvais
chiffre à la politique frileuse je cite
de lionel jospin et puis sachez qu'à
marseille
onze personnes soupçonnées d'appartenir
à un réseau de trafiquants de cocaïne
ont été interpellés quatre d'entre elles
ont été écrouées depuis l'an dernier on
assiste ainsi à une augmentation de la
délinquance des mineurs pour y faire
face tout ce début d'été a été marquée
par la volonté des maires d'instaurer
des couvre-feux dans leur ville pour les
moins de 13 ans au tribunal de bobigny
c'est une autre expérience qui a été
menée pour sensibiliser les jeunes à la
justice on leur a fait jouer le rôle de
magistrats ou d'avocats stéphanois
tenaires et dida
avocat général cela demande un minimum
de préparation et derrière son pupitre
samir est un peu tendue c'est un honneur
de new york
l'ensemble du président on est extra
jurés avocats de la défense ou de la
partie civile
25 jeunes de seine-saint-denis se
retrouve du côté de la justice dans la
salle d'assises deux mineurs sont
accusés de meurtre je vous appeler jean
claude teulet votre âge 16 ans un
magistrat professionnel encadre les
débats samir écoute et n'hésite pas à
poser des questions parfois
embarrassantes
combien de temps après la découverte du
corps avez vous alerter les autorités
follis les jurés se font peu à peu leur
opinion et tu fais pas téléphoné pour
qu'elle vienne c'est important quand
même les témoins défilent à la barre et
les accusés tente de se défendre une
heure et demie plus tard samir prend ses
réquisitions demande 20 ans de prison
ferme et 50 mille francs d'amendé à
diego c'était quand même des premiers
dit à sion je m'en occupe
je lui faire la peau pour moi si des
préméditation que j'ai mis la peine
maximum les jurés se sont retirés pour
délibérer
généralement les jeunes sont plus
sévères que la justice les deux accusés
auront la peine maximale vous allez
avoir délibéré ce n'était pas facile
mais en fait c'est en plus ensemble mais
on n'était pas tous d'accord ni sur la
majorité au départ il avait un rôle à
jouer quand ils ne l'ont pas joué ils
l'ont vécu
ils n'étaient pas il ne faut pas le rôle
du procureur général il ne jouait pas le
rôle de l'avocat il était le procureur
général il était l'avocat se sont
vraiment passionnés
cette fois ci pas de crédit de pleurs
mais beaucoup de questions aux
magistrats qui espère par ce genre
d'opération éviter de croiser un jour
ces jeunes gens dans une vraie cour
d'assises à bitche en moselle on est
toujours sans nouvelle de la jeune
karine mais des traces d'un gaz
lacrymogènes paralysant ont été
retrouvés sur la selle de son vélo ce
qui accrédite la piste de l'enlèvement
aurélia guillemin et patrick schumacher
lacrymogène a été retrouvée
on a trouvé des traces de gaz
lacrymogène sur la place audin fils a
été on
c'est pas à des choses qui n en parlait
à mia clair depuis dix jours que karine
a disparu les habitants de bitche n'ont
que des rumeurs auxquelles s'accrocher
aujourd'hui ce sont des traces de gaz
lacrymogène soi-disant détecté sur la
selle de vélo de karine qui font la une
des quotidiens mais à sarreguemines
les enquêteurs ne confirme pas cet
élément depuis l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire
il travaille dans le plus grand secret
jusqu'à présent la seule piste sérieuse
retenue a aussitôt été démentie
les deux militaires qui n'était pas
rentré de permissions le jour de la
disparition de karine sont eux mêmes
venus expliquer leur absence du camp de
fausses rumeurs en mauvaise piste
le seul élément fiable dont on dispose
en fait aujourd'hui est une mazda
blanche
aperçu par un témoin au moment des faits
en marge de l'enquète fabrice le frère
de karim continue lui de démarcher les
entreprises de la région
aujourd'hui il a obtenu le financement
et la distribution de plusieurs milliers
de nouvelles affiches la semaine
prochaine la photo de karine devrait
être présente dans plusieurs régions de
france
encore une confirmation et un communiqué
la confirmation tout d'abord un colis
piégé a bien été désamorcés au domicile
de jean guy talamoni le dirigeant
nationaliste et puis le communiqué signé
du flnc qui menacent et exige une
amnistie tout cela à la veille des
journées les plus nationalistes de corte
alliès garder guillaume fautrat sont sur
place à bastien
c'est au tour de ses sympathisants que
jean guy talamoni est apparue cet après
midi devant la presse plus soudés que
jamais derrière leur chef de file les
nationalistes ont condamné fermement les
tentatives d'attentats qui ont visé hier
l'élu corse et l'avocate marie hélène
mattei
s'ils disent tu ignorais les auteurs ils
sont tous prêts néanmoins a accusé
l'état français
ça ne vient pas de chez nous il n'ya pas
de dissidents il n'y a pas de gens assez
fou chez lui pour faire ça de toute
façon donc il est très clair que cela
vienne de l'extérieur de la mouvance
dont nous sommes des représentants à
cette étable nous n'avons pas
suffisamment d'éléments aujourd'hui pour
affirmer que c'est une action
barbouzardes ce que nous affirmons
aujourd'hui c'est que le jeu trouble de
l'état français permet aujourd'hui
toutes les déstabilisations les colis
piégés expédiés aux cabinets des deux
avocats nationalistes sont toujours en
cours d' expertise
il semblerait néanmoins qu'il soit de
même facture capable sinon de tués de
blessés grièvement
les enquêteurs creuse du côté des
ennemis de marylène mattei est à la
mauny parmi lesquels le présumé leader
clandestins d'armata corsa françois
santoni un raccourci un peu grossier
selon lui sûrement lui d'assassiner jean
guy talamoni a bien qu'on les huit
m'assassiner enfin porter le chapeau
et comme pour ajouter à la confusion le
flnc ce soir a revendiqué une partie des
récents attentats commis en corse
une liste qui exclut les attaques du
mois dernier contre la gendarmerie de
borgo et la caserne de crs de furiani
l'organisation armée signes sont
communiquées par un appel à la lutte
décidée à rompre définitivement avec la
trêve
deux figures nationalistes visé hier
sans compter les deux récentes attaques
contre les forces de sécurité dans le
nord de l'île crsc gendarmerie mobile
des événements qui n'ont toujours pas
été revendiqué qui pourraient être
attribués à des groupuscules dissidents
et incontrôlée des événements qui en
tout cas viennent encore brouiller un
peu plus l'image du nationalisme corse
les événements qui vont devoir peser sur
les négociations en cours à paris et qui
pourrait freiner ce processus de
matignon
un processus que beaucoup déjà ici
pendant ce temps plein
l'action n'est pas seulement symbolique
des dizaines de plaintes contre la
france pour crimes contre l'humanité
seront déposées à la fin du mois devant
le tribunal de grande instance de paris
ce sont les harkis qui veulent ainsi
faire reconnaître par la france qu'elle
les a abandonnés de façon délibérée à la
signature des accords d'évian 62
reportage près de villeneuve sur lot
isabelle de lyon et david bres elle a
été le cas c'est là moi j'étais mort
abdou fois je vous dis franchement c'est
quoi le dernier amant prisonniers du fln
ce harki a été torturé en algérie après
les accords d'evian
j'ai passé cinq ans de pression je veux
dire les salles qu'on a passé un savon
au moins une vingtaine d'années mme
cissé par pouce comme tous ses
compagnons il va porter plainte contre
la france pour crimes contre l'humanité
ces anciens soldats ont versé leur sang
pour que l'algérie reste française la
guerre terminée on les a désarmés
eux disent on les a envoyés au massacre
ils ont reçu les ordres comme quoi
encore en dix armes ils croient
dévorante il y est quand on le dirait qu
est ce qui se passait dès qu'on sort
deux camps ont problème à temps passe
les autres
les nationalistes algériens qu'ils
n'auront jamais pardonner leur
engagement dans l'armée française
officiellement 150 milliards qui ont été
massacrés après l'indépendance
selon les associations c'est la faute de
cet état ingrat qui les a abandonnés
donc condamnés
la sentence a été prononcée par la
france et le fln et la vindicte
populaire algérienne a été le bourreau
de cette atroce c'est pour ça que nous
on s'en prend pas l'algérie ne s'en
prend à la cause de tous nos malheurs et
de nos torture qui continue aujourd'hui
c'est à dire à l'état français
le comité national de liaison des harkis
espère avoir plusieurs centaines de
plaintes a déposé le 30 août prochain au
tribunal de grande instance de paris
comme la plupart des membres de son
gouvernement lionel jospin était en
vacances il est arrivé hier soir sur
l'île de ré où il a acheté une maison
l'automne dernier l'occasion pour le
premier ministre de commenter les
mauvais chiffres du chômage publiés hier
et puis de préciser avec quels fonds il
avait acheté cette maison alexandre kara
et philippe ya du vent dans les voiles
une mer calme et un bateau maniable en
somme un beau rêve d'un politique
à n'en pas douter si le capitaine jospin
pouvait gouverner la france comme tenir
la barre de ce voilier il ne s'en
plaindrait pas après le cycliste le
tennisman voici lionel jospin le marin
et lorsqu'on lui parle de dépression
économique ou de creux du chômage
il conserve le discours du capitaine au
long cours quant au chômage
nous avons eu 1 millions 78 mille
chômeurs de moins et il y a eu deux fois
deux mois à plus 5 milles plus une île
je ne m'en réjouis pas mais enfin c'est
sans son mesure par rapport à
l'amplitude du mouvement de baisse du
chômage est naturellement de création
d'emplois lunettes de soleil bermuda et
chaussures de bateaux le premier
ministre a déjà tout dit vacanciers
au programme sport lecture et des temps
dans cette maison de l'île de ré qu'il
vient de s'offrir une acquisition de
garantie 0% fonds spéciaux oui mais on
s'est dit que
peut-être au lieu de louer une maison
qui nous revenait un peu cher valait
peut-être faire un effort supplémentaire
en demandant les crédits à nos banques
ce que nous avons fait ma femme et moi
je suis maintenant on a cette petite
maison au mercy une demi-heure avec la
presse et voilà le premier ministre
débarrasser de ses obligations
médiatiques jusqu'au 23 août date du
conseil des ministres de la rentrée
trois semaines pour les vacances de
monsieur jospin le temps sans doute de
méditer un peu sur la grande régate
présidentielle qui se profile déjà à
l'horizon et jacques chirac et son
épouse bernadette sont arrivés au fort
de brégançon dans le var la durée de
leur séjour n'a pas été communiqué
deux nouveaux cas de lait jus de
légionellose ali ont cette fois il
s'agit de personnes âgées résidant dans
les 6ème et 8ème arrondissement la
préfecture a ordonné une enquête sur
toute l'agglomération lyonnaise ces deux
nouveaux cas portent à 12 le nombre de
personnes qui ont contracté la maladie
depuis la mi juin le doigt gadret et
thierry monnier 12 cas de légionellose
dans l'agglomération lyonnaise en un
mois une fréquence exceptionnel pour
cette maladie rare les victimes sont
essentiellement des hommes retraités ils
auraient été contaminées en se promenant
à proximité d'immeubles équipés de tours
aéroréfrigérantes la légionellose est
une
maladie qui est contractée par
l'inhalation de gouttelettes et en a
émis cette hypothèse que les personnes
auraient pu inhalé des gouttelettes qui
avait été émise par une de ces tours de
climatisation trois arrondissements de
lyon sont essentiellement concernés
l'installation en cause n'est pas
identifié au coeur de ces périmètres le
quartier d'affaires de la part dieu
si c'est arrivé à chavez est arrivé à
moi aussi j'en pense que c'est dangereux
et que je pense que les autorités vont
changer les réformes nécessaires ou les
visites de chais où les contrôles
nécessaires
le préfet a donc pris un arrêté les
exploitants de tours doit faire procéder
à une analyse de l'eau de leur circuit
de climatisation
chaque prélèvement donné lieu à une mise
en culture afin de détecter la présence
de bactéries
si un nombre très important de
legionella pneumophila probablement donc
qui seront confirmées après par les
tests complémentaires et les cultures
complémentaires
il faut 10 jours pour avoir des
résultats probants
les pouvoirs publics devront donc encore
attendre avant d'éventuellement
connaître la source contaminante
d'ici là de nouveaux cas pourraient être
enregistrés c'est bientôt la fin des
soldes il vous reste encore jusqu'à
lundi soir pour faire de bonnes affaires
mais déjà les commerçants se frottent
les mains leur chiffre d'affaires est en
hausse de 5% par rapport à l'an passé
qui était pourtant déjà une bonne année
reportage à paris de payer le roi et de
västra bouffartigue heures
rangé dans un coin de magasins on les
avait presque oublié les soldes l'eau
rayon des bonnes affaires est plutôt
restreint
il faut dire qu'il y à trois semaines
les boutiques étaient dévalisés
les sols de 2001 ont bien marché + 5 à
10% par rapport à 2000
la conjoncture a été bonne les français
rassuré ont libéré leur porte monnaie
ils préfèrent consommer par par grands
événements et notamment en période de
soldes ça a été le cas aux soldes de
janvier
c'est également le cas au mois de
juillet mais on a vu que dès le mois de
juin en fait les ménages ont eu envie de
consommer du coup les produits soldés
sont déjà presque épuisé début août en
pleine canicule les pubs de la
collection automne hiver occupe déjà la
majorité des escales vous le voyez ici
par exemple avant première une de nos
marques propres nous avons regroupé tout
ce qui nous reste en soldes à prix ronds
en tout à 49 francs ou tout à 99 francs
et nous présentons déjà sur la majeure
partie du rayon la nouvelle collection
automne hiver qui est très recherché de
la part de notre clientèle étrangère
mais il reste les irréductibles celle
pour qui ces affiches alléchantes marque
le vrai début des soldes alors elle
fouille elles cherchent elles testent
pendant la toute dernière semaine au
risque de rentrer brody
vous allez trouver quelque chose qui
vous plaît vaut mieux y a pas ma voiture
parce qu'ils ont encore de bonnes
affaires
je crois pas
il faut avoir de la chance aux de la
ténacité
les soldes se terminent lundi soir bon
courage et un bon chiffre également pour
la consommation les ventes de voitures
neuves ont augmenté de plus de 11% en
juillet une nouvelle étape dans le
passage à l'euro une étape symbolique
puisqu'elle concerne les fameux livret a
à la poste l'écureuil compte maintenant
en euros et plus offrant un choc pour 28
millions d'épargnants un reportage de
séverine lebrun et patrice wucher une
nouvelle fois l'euro va faire tourner la
tête des clients de la poste aujourd'hui
au guichet il était pratiquement sur
toutes les lèvres
aujourd'hui tout ce qui épargne et
bascule en europe remontant ici de vote
rennais seront effectivement tous les
livret d'epargne sont désormais tenues
en europe
une mini révolution qui n'a pas que des
avantages
ben ce que ça change c'est supérieur
beaucoup plus bas dans au début ça va
être galère des salles à partir du
moment
une petite calculette pour faire la
france nation de francs en euros et vice
et versa on ça devrait faciliter mais
j'imagine que pour certaines personnes
ça devrait être facile ça sera pas
facile jusqu'à présent les livrets
d'épargné étaient plafonnés à 100 mille
francs conversion faite vous pourrez
désormais placé quinze mille trois cents
euros au maximum un basculement préparé
depuis très longtemps
l'opération est de grande ampleur un
grand réseau en lice 7000 points de
contact sur les comptes d'épargné à 28
millions qu'on dépeint qui vont basculer
donc on est sur des grandes séries tout
est fait pour que l'informatique
tiennent et se passe dans de bonnes
conditions
mais la phase critique ce sera samedi
avec le versement des prestations
sociales ce qui les créditent rond sur
leurs livrets les verront apparaître en
euros
l'été c'est aussi l'époque des petits
boulots souvent une première expérience
pour beaucoup de jeunes un premier
contact avec le monde du travail
on peut se retrouver et plagistes barman
vendeur ou même policier municipal
reportage à la grande motte de caroline
gauthier et frédéric bibal parcours du
combattant en perspective pour alexandre
les jobs d'été deviennent denrée rare au
1er août
même à la grande motte alors mieux vaut
ne pas faire le difficile aujourd'hui
sur cuisine serveur barman vendeurs non
de gascon comme j'ai trop long pour
l'essai de toute façon ici l'activité
principale repose sur le tourisme la mer
et donc la plage et qui dit plage dit
transat
chaque jour guillaume installe les
matelas les jolies naïades aussi
visiblement il y prend plaisir
il ya le soleil en est bronzée je sens
fait des rencontres et peut être dire
des rencontres les rencontres avec les
forces
autre formule la vente de beignets ou de
glace sur la plage plus physique mais là
encore il y a plus à plaindre
on est au bord de la plage déjà on a les
pieds dans l'eau on discute avec les
gens c'est mieux que de faire la planche
inenvisageable donc pour mathieu de se
lever à 5 heures du matin et de balayer
les trottoirs
pourtant sa masse après tout l'après
midi de libre donc c'est pas un boulot
très contraignant on est un peu tout
seul c'est enfin je suis de faire son
boulot correctement il ya parfois un
petit demandes d'horaires jessica
travail dans un univers un peu plus
particulier plus original en tout cas
c'est le bruit des machines à sous qui
ponctuent ces journées comment vous de
faire venir les gens en face pour les
boissons et de ramadi
voilà une ged les bars mais drogba quant
à eric et stéphane il troque cet été le
maillot de bain contre l'uniforme de
policier municipal différentes
interventions qu'on peut pas avoir dans
notre métier ça c'est assez diversifié
donc jours les interventions pour des
vols et cambriolages des agressions des
bagarres c'est ce qui fait le charme
sécurité enfin ne rêvons pas nos
apprentis policiers ne sont pas des cow
boys pour autant ils ne portent pas
d'armes et surtout ils sortent toujours
bien encadrés pour les verts c'est sans
doute le convoi de déchets nucléaires le
plus important jamais assemblé un
nouveau train a quitté l'allemagne
aujourd'hui à destination de la france
et l'angleterre greenpeace manifestera
surtout le trajet les verts protestent
depuis la reprise des transports le 26
mars dernier c'est le sixième convoi qui
quitte l'allemagne de cette façon arrivé
en france il devrait se dédoubler une
partie poursuivant sa route vers l'
usine de la hague
et puis l'autre vers l'angleterre en
israël au lendemain de la taxe sur la
pelouse au cours de laquelle six
militants du hamas et deux enfants ont
été tués le gouvernement revendique son
droit à l'autodéfense et sa politique
d'assassinats ciblés
côté palestinien on appelle à la
vengeance en enterrant est mort sur
place
charles enderlin les groupes armés du
hamas étaient devant l'hôpital de
naplouse ce matin lors de la levée des
corps c'est le commando azzedine el
qassam la branche militaire du mouvement
intégriste avec en blanc les candidats
au suicide et leur ceinture d'explosifs
et le cortège s'est formé
toutes les organisations palestiniennes
étaient représentées y compris le fatah
de yasser arafat
une foule considérable 80 peut être cent
mille personnes a participé aux
funérailles des huit palestiniens
hier par l'armée israélienne le ton des
slogans et très dur vengeance vengeance
est aussi jihad jihad guerre sainte
tous promettent des représailles rapide
et sanglante en israël après les
obsèques de brefs accrochages ont opposé
l'armée israélienne à de jeunes lanceurs
de pierres à l'entrée de naples il des
scènes identiques se sont déroulés à des
manifestations à ramallah et à hébron
ici où de violents échanges de tirs ont
éclaté en début d'après midi
un civil palestinien a été tué à
jérusalem où la sécurité a été renforcée
dans la trappe de nouveaux attentats
ariel sharon a réuni son cabinet de
sécurité
il a décidé de poursuivre sa politique
de liquidation je cite des terroristes
et de leurs commanditaires avec la
riposte prévu du ramasse la région
s'attend à un nouveau cycle de
représailles peut-être encore plus dur
que les précédents
rien ne semble pouvoir l'arrêter même la
décision du g8 d'envoyer sur place des
observateurs internationaux est restée
lettre morte en irlande l'ombre et du
blessé est toujours de mettre fin aux
violences et de relancer la mise en
oeuvre des accords de paix du vendredi
saint dans leur nouvelle proposition les
deux gouvernements continuent de
considérer le désarmement de l'irak
comme indispensable mais ne fixe
curieusement aucun échéancier catholique
comme protestant doivent se prononcer
d'ici lundi
une petite révolution en allemagne les
premiers mariages homosexuels ou plutôt
les premiers packs sont été célébrée
aujourd'hui
les mairies allemande ce fut le cas
rambour cologne ou encore berlin
mais tous les landes ne sont pas sur la
même longueur d'onde dans certains états
régionaux plus conservateurs comme la
bavière
la loi ne devrait pas entrer en vigueur
avant l'automne
aux etats unis la chambre des
représentants interdit le clonage humain
y compris à des fins thérapeutiques
le texte approuvé par les républicains
avait le soutien du président bush et il
doit être maintenant à être approuvé par
le sénat
mais cette décision est saluée par le
vatican jean paul ii s'en était
entretenu avec george bush
à l'issue du sommet du g8 à gênes benoît
thevenet avec isabelle bechler à new
york 10 ans de prison amende d'un
million de dollars le texte voté par les
parlementaires américains est clair il
interdit toute forme de clonage
même si c'est à des fins thérapeutiques
le clonage thérapeutique présente l
avantage pour certains scientifiques de
disposer à volonté de cellules souches
ces cellules dites indifférenciée sont
prélevées sur un embryon de cinq jours
appelées blastocystes elles ont la
capacité une fois mises en culture
d'évoluer en cellules du coeur du foie
du rein injecté ensuite dans l'organe en
question elles ont la capacité de le
coloniser d'éventuellement le réparer
ces cellules cardiaques par exemple
peuvent régénérer un choeur abîmé par un
infarctus
mais pour d'autres chercheurs pionniers
en la matière nul besoin de cloner pour
obtenir ces fameuses cellules souches
elles sont déjà prélevables sur les
embryons congelés et se reproduisent
très facilement à partir d'un soupçon de
cellules on peut faire des quantités
invraisemblables de tissu ils vont se
multiplier se multiplier et il suffit de
prélever de temps en temps ces cellules
est orienté leur croissance pour en
faire des cellules nerveuses ou les
cellules musculaires
donc nous n'avons pas besoin de nouveaux
embryons régulièrement et pas nécessaire
la décision de la chambre des
représentants va dans le sens de ce que
font la plupart des pays européens une
interdiction totale du clonage pour nos
risques et aucune dérive je crois que
les gouvernements savent très bien que
par rapport à leurs peuples
il aurait pris une responsabilité
considérable considérable véritablement
si par manque de vigilance
il avait aidé à ce passage qui est tout
de même funeste c'est-à-dire à
l'utilisation du clonage pour faire
naître des bébés mais le débat aux états
unis n'est pas définitivement clos
car pour être validée le
projet de loi sur l'interdiction du
clonage devra être étudié par les
sénateurs américains dans les prochaines
semaines
comme chaque année à la même époque
l'angleterre s'inquiète de l'état de
santé de sa reine mère c'est bientôt son
anniversaire ses 101 ans et elle vient
d'être hospitalisée à la suite d'une
légère fatigue due à la chaleur qui fait
suffoquer les anglais mais pas question
de rater son anniversaire la queen mum
sera bien devant sa résidence samedi
elle a promis comme le veut la tradition
les révélations du journal libération
ont fait l'effet d'une bombe dans le
milieu de l'athlétisme l'an dernier aux
jeux de sydney la délégation française
avait emporté 580 médicaments
différentes dont 18 strictement interdit
aux sportifs pour quel usage en tout cas
pas pour doper les athlètes affirme le
comité national olympique
reportage de julien beaumont et de
pierre ludovic viol
cette liste aurait dû rester secrète
c'est trop tard voici l'énumération de
tous les médicaments emporté par la
délégation française à signer une
trousse à pharmacie bien fourni 580
produits pour 341 athlètes cherchez
l'erreur 36 ne sont disponibles que sur
ordonnance plus grave 18 sont tout
simplement interdits par le cio
dans la délégation il ya aussi des non
sportifs
il n'y a pas forcément des gens aussi en
parfaite santé sans vous dévoiler des
secrets je peux vous dire qu'il nous
faut nous prémunir en médicaments pour
soigner ces gens là des produits
interdits prévus pour des non sportifs à
vouloir jouer les bons samaritains le
comité olympique français est
aujourd'hui dans l'embarras mais pas à
court d'arguments les médicaments dont
il est question et qui ont été
effectivement emporté aux jeux
olympiques sont des médicaments que tout
médecin doit avoir en sa possession s'il
veut effectivement pourvoir en procéder
à des soins en cas d'urgence des
situations d'urgence prévues par le
règlement olympique
si jamais un athlète est soignée avec un
médicament interdit
il est immédiatement exclu de la
compétition à ciney les français ont
décroché 38 médailles et subit 95
contrôles antidopage
aucun ne s'est révélé positif
à chacun son everest c'est le nom d'une
association créée par une jeune femme à
chamonix elle est médecin et alpiniste
je ne vois pas pourquoi les enfants
gravement malades ne pourrait pas se
confronter à la montagne reportage de
cendrars et spock et yves mânes s'est
surpassé pour atteindre le sommet c'est
l'objectif d'aujourd'hui 16 petits
toulousains venus respirer l'air de
chamonix pendant une semaine sept colons
est un peu particulière chacun de ses
enfants à traverser la maladie cancer ou
leucémie
à force d'être à l'hôpital tu t'ennuies
est tous là tu vois ça te change lutter
un peu parce que souvent tu dois être
enfermé dans tes chambre spécifique août
à fall même pas loin de sortir un petit
peu
cela fait huit ans que christine jana a
créé l'association à chacun son everest
médecin et alpiniste de profession elle
allie ses deux passions pour aider les
enfants à sa manière les faire passer du
malheur à l'exploit
l'enfant il et on lui fait faire des
choses que personne ne croyait lui même
ne croyait pas capable de faire et en
même temps le responsabiliser porte on
sai qui fait son lit à l'hôpital on lui
fait tout on est obligé l'escaladent un
autre défi à relever guide animateur
infirmières et médecins sont là pour les
rassurer
la petite troupe est bien entouré car la
plupart d'entre eux n'ont jamais grimpé
une fois équipé à eux de jouer
j'aime fait arriver ça fait peur mais
c'est un peu quand même
et rien n'empêche les réticences se
vident passait pas on est resté au sol
et pour prouver aux parents que c'est
pas pour defour les photos et la vidéo
souvenir témoigne cette semaine aura
permis aux enfants et aux parents de
souffler christine elle a rempli sa
mission faire oublier un peu le passé
oui plus de rabais plus dramatique un
alpiniste de 45 ans s'est tué ce matin
dans le massif du mont-blanc il a
dévissé pendant l'ascension de
l'aiguillé verte son guide est
grièvement blessé comment empêcher la
langoustine sans massacrer les petits
merlus un pêcheur de saint guénolé a
trouvé la solution il ya quelques années
il a installé sur son chalutier un
filets à mailles sélective
à l'époque peu de gens s'y intéresser
mais depuis que l'espèce est menacée
vaucelles il voit peut-être la solution
pour sauver leymergie reportage d'audrey
goasguen et jean yves blanc la belle
mort
le vent de mer il est 5h30 le chalutier
file vers le large
c'est l'heure pour robert bouguéon de
jeter les premiers chalut les filets qui
vont récolter les langoustines des
filets bien particulier il ya quatre ans
robert a été le premier en france à
expérimenter sur son bateau un nouveau
filer un chalut sélectif qui lui permet
de pêcher des langoustines tout en
évitant de capturer des poissons trop
jeu objectif ne pas détruire la faute
combien est
mary jo foley faisant on doit pas
l'empêcher de renault
et ce qui permet de les laisser partir
sur son bateau
robert a installé d'un côté son nouveau
dispositif sélectif à mailles carrées et
de l'autre un filet standard pour les
comparer à mike harris malvy à l'envers
elle est ouverte
elle est constamment ouverte dans l'eau
vegas qu'elle laisse s'échapper dit pas
son salut traditionnel ou l'émail
confirmés ils sont constamment fermés
derrien qui s'échappe
résultat le filet sélectif prend deux
fois moins de petits merlus une
différence de taille puisque ce poisson
est en voie d'extinction
il ya deux mois le commissaire européen
à la pêche a passé une journée en mer
sur la belle mort et a été convaincu par
le dispositif
aujourd'hui neuf autres bateaux ont été
équipés pour réaliser des tests mais
beaucoup de pêcheurs ne sont pas encore
prêts à franchir le pas
les collections ils ont peur de perdre
aussi
c'est sympa si patrick lormand a poussé
la préfon
l'union européenne menace d'interdire la
capture des langoustines
si les pêcheurs ne se mettent pas
d'accord sur une solution une solution
pour restaurer une pêche plus
responsable troisième journée de
canicule et 3e série d' alerte à la
pollution c'est le sud-est qui souffrent
le plus notamment les bouches du rhône à
paris bertrand delanoë demande au
gouvernement de modifier les seuils au
delà desquels l'on peut déclencher la
circulation alternée
du côté de la normandie où la chaleur
est tout à fait supportable les
touristes et même les habitants
paraissent loin de ces préoccupations
reportage de dorothée cochard et
guillaume viard 3 4 et 5 doigts de pieds
grand écart petite lecture version
bateau gonflable
ils se plaignent de la chaleur en ville
voici ce qu'on en pense ici il fait
chaud après il fait un peu plus chaud
après il va faire trop chaud après
légèrement son plein aux flammes
après yaya près savoir-faire des orages
après il pleut des gens se plaignent
encore là ça vous plaît pas ah oui quand
il répondu oui parce que nous nous avons
une région il fait pas tellement bon si
tristes années comme beaucoup de but de
pluie alors bien que maintenant on
cherche soleil quoi voilà envier aux
indécis ouistreham une des plus belles
plages de basse normandie ce mois de
juillet est un des meilleurs via des
signes et ne venez pas dire aux
restaurateurs que le soleil est néfaste
l'équation elle était très simple déjà
pour le moment s'il ya votre soleil a
pas de personne n'y a pas de monde s'il
ya du monde s'il fait du soleil dans le
cas du monde et s'il ya du monde on
travaille voilà la démonstration est
clair soleil est synonyme de bonne
affaire pour les restaurateurs pour les
familles chasseurs de coqs et pour les
indiana jones en herbe
il faut pas avancer plus
le soleil de la plage se décline en 3 a
à faire aventure et et amour témoignage
de la le dos des bacs à sable
si vous regardez autour de lui pas très
bienvenu c'est vrai que c'est excitant à
tous et c'est vrai c'est très bien on
met bas il faut qu'enfin ces deux ratios
peut se faire autant et si des gens ont
changé quoi je pense mais voilà il ya
plus qu'à conclure pour les citadins
récalcitrants ils sont les bienvenus ils
n'ont pas un nuage à l'horizon et ici il
n'ya vraiment pas de quoi se plaindre
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres ce sont
les chiffres qui inquiètent et qui
s'annonce au coeur de la prochaine
campagne électorale la délinquance a
augmenté de près de 10% au cours du
premier semestre
pour l'opposition c'est le résultat de
la politique de lionel jospin
et puis en corse alors que les colis
piégés sont désamorcées aux domiciles de
personnalités nationalistes le flnc met
en garde
l'heure est à la butte disent les
clandestins seule une amnistie peut
régler les problèmes tout de suite la
météo avec nathalie rihouet 23h55 ce
sera et les nus pour le dernier journal
de maintenant les quatre vérités à 7h50
l'invité sera colette avital députés à
la knesset
à 13h le journal présenté par empreintes
duriez une connerie et quant à moi
j'aurais l'immense plaisir de vous
retrouver ici aux alentours de 20h bonne
soirée sur france 2